Researchers at Vanderbilt University developed
an app that analyzes shockwaves from bullets
to determine the location of snipers.
And a belgian designer has created smart, polymer
furniture that's self-assembling, and grows
like popcorn.
Vsauce! Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
SOINN is an artificial brain that can now
use the internet to learn new things. Developed
at the Tokyo Institute of Technology, the
machine learning algorithm can learn about
objects using image searches. It also has
the ability to take aspects of other objects
and combine them to make guesses about things
that it doesn't recognize. By storing characteristics
of objects like pens and knives being stick-shaped
, it can then further differentiate them and
determine, for instance, what a box cutter
is. And it can pick out features from audio
and video data, and its in development for
autonomous mental development robots.
Intel and Carnegie Mellon University are creating
headlights that make raindrops disappear.
Each headlight is actually a projector instead
of a lamp - and it has a camera which picks
up the raindrops - and then a processor predicts
their path, darkens those pixels - making
the raindrops invisible. But unfortunately
they say this technology probably won't be
commercially available for a decade.
Triangle Tree has created edible spoons. With
disposable plastic spoons taking more than
20 years to decompose, this eco-friendly alternative
is made from all-organic ingredients and comes
in three flavors. It also has weakened lines
on the back so its easer it break off and
eat.
Ultimate Bloody Mary!
Wool&Prince are making wool button down shirts
that last six times longer than cotton, are
naturally anti-wrinkly and odor-fighting.
Founder Mac Bishop demonstrated the longevity
of the fine grade wool fabric by wearing the
same shirt for a hundred days straight without
washing it. For more information find the
link below...
This bright green robot mecha suit was built
by Japanese robotics company Sakakibara Kikai.
It's called the Kid's Walker Cyclops and comes
equipped with one arm for grabbing and the
other has a drill. It's about 6'9" tall and
3'6" wide and weighs 750 lbs. It costs $20,500
to own but is also available to rent.
This robot can tell what a human
is so it doesn't crush them. Roboticists from
Georgia Tech and San Francisco based Meka
robots built a robot arm with sensitive skin
giving it the ability to reach through cluttered
areas carefully, as well as gently touch a
human - shown here lifting a blanket for a
disabled man who claims that the arm never
pressed hard against him, and he felt safe
using it.
Finally "lightspin" by Eric Pare and Timecode
Lab has dancers illuminated combining bullet
time photography, stop motion, and light painting.
I'm gonna leave you with a laser shooting
through 100 balloons, and, as always - thanks
for watching.